that X is X launched in 1998 the Lexus
RX was one of the first luxury and
lifestyle SUVs to hit the market it was
a big hit in the US and shifted over 2.2
million units worldwide sales in Europe
have been more reserved those as our
current system I know
Lexus now hopes to change that with a
new design and a beefy love it or hate
it grille unlike in the US Lexus is no
major player in Germany but fancies its
chances with the fourth edition of the
rx it has enhanced powertrain
state-of-the-art vehicle safety systems
and new interior features
that X is X this Lexus is no racing
machine although it boosts 313
horsepower Notestine hood fully
utilizing that output puts the car under
audible strain he finds this and the
overly sensitive suspension
disappointing
although the cars refined and luxurious
interior design almost makes up for it
the car's interior is highly functional
that exudes an air of luxury passengers
are surrounded by an array of
top-quality materials
a wave of the hand over the Lexus badge
opens the trunk
inside you'll find a storage capacity of
539 liters you can triple that volume by
lowering the power folded backseats
we tested the RX 450h luxury line model
it boasts a hybrid drive with a 3.5
liter direct injection v6 gasoline
engine combined with the electric motors
it has an output of 230 kilowatts this
all adds up to a fuel economy of 5.3
liters on 100 kilometers and sells in
Germany for a whopping seventy six
thousand four hundred euros
the new RX remains true to the dynamic
design elements of the current Lexus
family
the l-shaped rear lights are one of the
trademark features
well I think the RX can go for about one
kilometer on electric power says line
would more would be better but to
remodel the RX into a plug-in hybrid
would be too complicated the new 2-liter
turbocharged 200 t might be an
alternative the basic model is about
26,000 euros cheaper than the RX and
Germany it will set you back just under
50,000 euros but it consumes 7.8 liters
of gasoline per 100 kilometers more than
the hybrid
you